good morning John first things first
project for awesome is coming and it's
coming fast project for awesome gonna be
a little bit different this year and
it'll take place almost exclusively on
youtube.com so if you want to
participate at all even if you're just
tuning in for a little bit you need to
go right now to youtube.com slash p4a
and subscribe right now it is extremely
important to the success of the project
for us and that you do that once again
right now however many views this video
gets Matt as how many people I expect to
be subscribed to youtube.com slash p4a
people this is for charity now if you
are going to make a video you also need
to go subscribe to youtube.com slash P
for a but you should also go to the
links in my pants to get the thumbnail
now only partners can change their
thumbnail if you're not a partner you
can't change through some nail that's
fine you can still participate in the
project but you should put project for
awesome or p4a in the title of your
video and put both of those things in
the tags so that we can find your
project for awesome video you must then
upload those videos at midnight ish on
December 17th and then throughout the
17th and 18th the project for awesome
crew including John and I will be
featuring those videos all over the
place on projects are awesome comm on
our mailing list on the front page of
YouTube and at youtube.com slash p4a now
on Wednesday I was in Washington DC and
when we go places we do thoughts from
places good morning John I woke up this
morning at 6 a.m. and then 6:30 and then
again at 7:30 because apparently and I
guess somewhat unsurprisingly Washington
DC must have more trash than any other
city on the planet but then the garbage
truck stopped coming and I woke up
blissfully at around 10 a.m.
dramatically entered my fancy though
somewhat tiny hotel room turned off
simply noise calm which helped me sleep
but failed to drown out the garbage
trucks and then I took a shower from a
showerhead that looked remarkably like
the planetary defense system that the
crew of the Starship Enterprise had to
battle in the second season of Star Trek
TNG it totally freaked me out I was
afraid was gonna put me in a stasis
field and then I noticed this mirror and
then I noticed this other mirror I
noticed that there's a hinge on one of
them and I was trying to figure out why
this mirror has a hinge and then I
realized it's so you can do this
they pretty much thought of everything
here at this hotel and then I
dramatically left my hotel because
apparently my hotel has a thing for
curtains and then I was released onto
the streets of Washington DC I enjoyed
my walk seeing many monuments of
monumental people this here is Horace
trickle Tinley famous cabbage fancier
and here we have Engelbert Hume art who
triumphed at the Battle of Upper Little
Big Ten and then I wandered past the
giant temple to Peskin ruscus the
Zoroastrian god of penetration and
finally we have the monument of Anju
tell a tale a day late on the inventor
of both velcro and the pencil sharpener
and then by random chance I ran into
quizzical cool easy flip the squirrel
ambassador to the United States we had a
brief conversation in which he
apologized for the crimes of scuzzy
kazoos all and informed me that since
the passage of the squirrel friendliness
and cleanliness Act of 1982 there has
been a dramatic decrease in squirrel
related fatalities so little not of fact
the squirrels will only approach humans
for two things food and to be on YouTube
okay seriously though Washington DC
really is an amazing place it's a place
where you feel the power of our nation's
past much more viscerally I was in DC
for a little event thingy that YouTube
was throwing for policy and politics
people I was on a panel about using
YouTube for good in which I thought all
about the project for awesome of course
it was fun but way too short and I wish
I had taken some video of the amazing
Indian food I got John I'll see you on
Monday don't forget to go to
youtube.com/scishow and subscribe
you can do that right now that's the
only thing I'm devoting this end screen
to p4a youtube concepts before you go
subscribe now you can also subscribe to
get email updates that is probably a
good idea as well you will not regret
this decision